yeah game is handy
it will eventually kick us yeah
i am broadcasting myself but none of
your audio so
you're all fine they can't hear you i
just sound like i'm talking to myself
it's great
don't worry about it
i don't know that it's a good strategy
it's just what i'm doing
that
ah there it is
i'll have to start a new one but i'm
just gonna wait a little bit until
everyone's uh ready to go
definitely not that now
okay
all right
oh i haven't i have to make a new game
hang on uh
do that do that do that there we go
i will give you guys a new code
no styma i'm foreign
here we go
i don't think so
okay
just very own brand
huh
what was that somebody just opened a
cold one
not quite what i was going for
smash and pan it all out here
nah
i do say sweater too i won't say um
anything in fahrenheit though they're
not getting me on that
uh who are we missing
sure i don't mind
yeah i'm gonna go live with your audio
everybody can hear everybody is
everybody in the game
oh hello i didn't realize holly was here
in just a second okay and i didn't know
when the right time was to be like hi
i'm here anytime yeah
hey hi i'm ollie how's the sun
holly is ruthless just bt dubs
you can't tell anybody that you never
passed
ruthless oh this is gonna be
so fun everyone alana did you put the
new code in or am i in the oh i'm in the
asia server
that might be it
okay andrea are you live nope
[Music]
i am not because i wanted to get in the
game but i'm about to be live i just
needed to get everything set up
because i probably should have done this
earlier
but i didn't because i was relaxing
i need your help what do you need help
with mad
none of my audio is working on my stream
no like no one can hear any of it
yeah i mean desktop and all that is up
but it's not flashing and there's no
sound it's just muted but nothing's
muted
even your mic or just your desktop audio
uh even my mic but obviously it's on
because you can hear me
indeed hmm uh so what i would say is
double check your discord settings and
make sure that you're in and out or what
you want them to be and then make sure
that your obs is set to the same in and
out as your discord
it's streamlabs well streamlabs obs
[Music]
blobs
sometimes when you do a pc reset it
changes what your default audio is
and if your streamlabs obs is set to
default audio then that can mess with
your discord pickup
i did a pc
jig welcome yeah
my chat is there for you mod they're all
talking about how you've had such a hard
tech day
oh my god we've drawn voodoo
[ __ ] together today we have gone through
it together
what does your post-it say on your face
it's dumb it says though
oh no yeah
oh my god it's okay i don't like
you hear me we can hear you in disco
i am still able to hear you yes
[Music]
they can hear me yeah what
yeah that's true said with me yet again
i got you girl you have every single
time god
supposed to have this like sponsored pc
build thing happening this month that
might end up happening
next year and i was literally like i
don't really know
confidently that i could do this and not
break it so i'm just gonna
ask trish when it happens i'll just be
like hey
you want to come build a pc with me
that'd be cool
i would love that uh
so what is your discord output in your
discord settings
uh-huh yeah yeah yeah make sure that
whatever that is set to
that you're also picking that up in your
stream labs obs
andrea do you have a dog
she's got a little blue dog so jealous
about
all right oh my gosh so cute do the
thing
everybody looks like are we uh how are
we doing i'm officially streaming now
yeah is everybody is everybody good for
me to press start so all i'm gonna say
is you mute while you play and deafen
and discord um and i can play with the
settings throughout different rounds or
whatever but um
we will when someone calls a meeting or
whatever is when you start talking i
have ejects off so we won't see if
someone get kicked
gets kicked out um two imposters
visual toss are on all that good stuff
you ready to go yes yes
please don't kill me especially if it's
miranda because then i will never trust
again
[Music]
i think you [ __ ] hate to see it you
guys you [ __ ]
it is miranda but it's okay because
it is also v
[Laughter]
all right um by the way everyone we're
raising money for black girls code the
link is in the description on youtube
and in like one of the panels
on twitch which whatever i don't
remember what they're even called
twitch doesn't make any sense what are
you guys doing just hanging out
here is that what are you just gonna
stand around what is
why is that the thing that's happened
all right well we could roll together
miranda we could roll together
they updated the game for halloween
they made it all halloweeny okay
let's roll let's roll we did that we did
some good work
kill zombie kill zombie we're gonna do
it we're gonna do it we're going to do
it we're going to do it
[ __ ] she didn't do it
that was quick that was hello
oh i was hoping it was me because i'm
still having
moved yet guys i did see that you had
you were just sitting there
i have not moved
my alibi is my incompetence
uh joey and holly you're still muted
i'm gonna let you guys know i found the
body going
okay towards navigation and i saw
somebody green but upon looking at this
little roster of people i realized that
there's two different shades of green
and i'm very confused
so it wasn't me because i haven't moved
can anyone verify that someone
trisha can vouch for me yeah because i'm
dead right
i can pretty much that is correct joey
sorry all right joe i miss you
holly and i were both an admin doing
tasks
so i was originally with joey and then i
went to engines and i
passed zombae but joey was still alive
when i was with her
where's i thought when i went into admin
because
and i think trisha might have seen me
stop because i saw zombie come up from
the bottom of admin which i feel like is
weird because i feel like nobody goes
that way
when they leave admin do you know what i
mean
how are we going to um how i walk
through the hallway
it's just something i pointed out i'm
not saying it's a it means anything
walking [ __ ] us
i'm not this brave to do a self-report
this early and holly went ahead
under the bus so i'm gonna say let's
vote for holly cause she's great i'm
skipping vote because i don't think this
sounds like anybody has
i also think i should skip photos zombie
has never come that hard for me this is
very
[Laughter]
[Music]
holly had two solid times that she could
have killed me and did
just throwing that out there marinated i
thought it was on maybe
a specific color is pretty important but
oh yeah i guess everyone keep an eye on
the two greens this is the only thing
worth noting yeah
andrea you don't want to vote
there you go all right i do feel like
i'll die okay okay
okay
[Music]
we didn't deserve to get away with that
at all miranda and i did not [ __ ]
deserve any of that [ __ ]
now it was real obvious i guess you just
didn't notice also for the record we are
playing with a
couple of new players um why is
everybody just [ __ ] standing around i
want to like what are you what are you
all [ __ ] doing here you know what's
everybody just standing around for
i better just go down i guess because
now rihanna's gonna think i'm following
her and i don't want that the kill
cooldown takes way too long dude
it takes way too long just pretend to do
this that's fine
oh i just need to do this everything's
fine it's going great it's going great
where is task let's just in here i can
kill him okay
well we just let it happen oh [ __ ] they
did it
i keep being so close to like being able
to kill someone and then not doing it oh
miranda
you could you could you could no there's
too many people too many people
[ __ ] i hate it so much okay
let's do that and let's [ __ ] peace
out
because i don't think anybody saw me
head in that direction just now
all right all right all right all right
wow green's dead
so the other green there's only one
green left one green remains
but there were so many people who saw me
all the time i actually do feel like i
was kind of around everyone that whole
time i'm trying to think of who i
haven't seen
trish where were you i don't think i saw
you i
was running from doing a task in
electrical over to reactors to shut that
down and then i went down to lower
engine to do a task and then i went up
to med bay and i was in med bay doing a
task when
uh the meeting was called that's pretty
confident
trish is a terrible liar
i did see her over in the reactor
okay i was with trish in electrical
earlier
uh i who was i most recently around i
saw
miranda i saw maude i think i saw
someone on cams actually
was someone on campus did you see
anything it was it was me
uh i didn't see anything suspicious no
[Music]
and i did reactor with mod and miranda
yes yes yeah i saw you in there too uh
zombae
i guess where where was body et cetera
the body was by
uh outside of electrical like that
little corner area and i had just
left doing a task an admin with i
believe steimer
yeah who doesn't have an alibi wait so
trish you said you were coming from
electrical to over to reactor right
i went from electrical to reactor and
then when i saw
that i think it was holly and miranda
had already done it i was trying to
think who was in that room
i was in the re i joined the reactor
room right as you guys finished it to do
my task in that room somebody else was
in the room
with me but i'm gonna be honest and say
i don't remember who because i'm still
like trying to set stuff up on my stream
as well
when you come out of the electrical
there's like that little left quarter
we're gonna run out of time
is being quiet i don't know i don't like
what
i'm skipping i don't know i don't know i
don't know i don't know
self-reporting
that's true she is the one throwing
everything around
two self reports is a little bold and i
know i'm a bold woman that's a good
point
it's a good point
okay clearly we're playing with people
who are new because that one i think i
deserve to get away with but in general
don't think i deserve to get away with
the first one at all
miranda you gotta [ __ ] help me out
here you gotta do some [ __ ] miranda you
gotta you gotta pull through for me fam
she's so sweet though so like i just
feel like if we just stay together
miranda do we oh nice nice good stuff
nice if we just hang out we can double
kill right
do it do it do it do it ah [ __ ]
nah miranda
that's a pretty quick deplete i don't
know what we're supposed to do here
though
okay
whoa saw that oh i saw it
you saw it yes it was okay
wait what no go ahead oh miranda
definitely killed
this timer in time is gone
yeah so i came in and i found blue who's
blue steimer so i found steimer dead
and then i was very confused
okay wait so holly did you see miranda
kill steinwell
i saw the body fall over
o2 just got fixed and trish knows i
fixed the top one
and then ran over another one yeah holly
and i were both together and ran to the
top one
and then ran to the bottom one and as we
ran in the room for the bottom one it
was already done and holly went in there
and i didn't
and we did ran past alana too so i was
trying to figure out how to get to o2
because i don't know this map and i
found steimer's body dead
and i just walked around a room to see
if anybody else is in there and holly
came in as well
i mean i guess like i saw a lot
of i don't know what to do here i passed
a lot of you guys this time because i
don't like a lot of people frankly i
went the wrong way up to electrical
rather than down but
uh wait so i feel like but you saw
miranda
did you actually see her dude like was
timer alive and then she wasn't alive
trish what did you just do i didn't see
you killed but i saw the body fall over
i think he thought that because the o2
just got fixed that no one would come
back in
okay i'm voting for miranda yeah i just
i i also
uh voted for miranda based on holly's
witness account and also don't know this
map this is the only map people know but
also if holly is blatantly lying about
this then we know to vote holly
that is true this would be like big big
brain
iq from holly for sure
okay that's unfortunate miranda that's
unfortunate this is gonna be a lot
harder on my own
but i do feel like versus the people
that i usually play with nobody's like
comment on me for any shouldn't use that
phrasing
nobody's coming at me about anything you
know i'm not like being blamed for
really anything at all i don't want to
do it too i don't know that i want to do
a task i just want to [ __ ]
find someone by themselves to kill i
[ __ ] hate being imposters so much
oh my god also uh this is for charity
you guys
you know i'm shaking because i do it
every time that i have to murder my
friends um it's thoughts
uh you please donate where is your body
for black girls code they basically
teach girls from 7 to 17 i believe are
the ages
um how to code
it is a super cool initiative and i
would highly recommend
you become a part of it i gotta kill you
dude i gotta kill you this is this is a
risk though too so
we just gotta do that and then we got a
belt
nobody saw me so
that should be all right
i made the timer so long they're gonna
finish their tasks
i have to kill a lot of people calms
do i have to just kill one more how many
people do i have to kill other than this
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] it's too long
[ __ ] okay we just jump here
i don't know
i gotta stop them from finishing their
[ __ ] tasks man
okay cool
i don't know how many more people i have
to kill
i think it's two which means that i
don't think that i could oh
okay okay what'd you see holly
uh i just left all of you the three of
you in comms
and went up to admin and andrea is dead
so the only person who wasn't in comms
then
if i'm correct was zombie
yes because all of you ran past me
just standing by her because i didn't
know
why she was just standing there so i'm
done with all my tasks no i just
stood there um but then she ran to the
left so i don't know i mean
i can absolutely vouch for trisha
because her and i've been running around
doing
um jobs this entire time
first one to get to coms you guys walked
in while still doing the stupid dial
[ __ ]
yeah you know it doesn't look good for
your girl
yeah sorry do you want to say something
what's your defense she just voted who
did you vote for it
i wrote it for holly i just don't trust
her okay
[Music]
choice
is that a good thing
[Music]
no i just have to kill one more right
the the countdown timer is so long
so i don't know what i'm supposed to do
like but i'm pretty sure it's just one
yeah it's just one of them
or is it two there's no way i could
[ __ ] kill two of them that's that's
absolutely impossible okay
oh [ __ ]
i would like to sabotage we could do it
and then i can just go to
wait till someone comes here to do o2
right
and then kill them [ __ ] we'll wait for
it to time out
i think i i don't know that i can do two
this is not gonna [ __ ] work there's
no way
anybody anybody
i just wait for it to timeout oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay oh no mod is dead
okay mod was over on the left side of
the back
so she went with you to the left but
then
i don't know how she got over to the
right but she's dead
yeah she's dead right on o2
which i had just gone to fix to find her
body because
the first one was done walk past trish i
think doing it
uh i didn't i didn't do the bottom one i
think holly did it i did before i got
there
i walked past someone there walked to
the second one and maude's dead
so what were you doing then trish i was
going to oxygen i went to bottom oxygen
and then saw holly already did it and i
[ __ ] killed her all right
i didn't think holly would come i
thought it would time out on o2
we had three seconds left holly three
seconds left
but i was like they'll just they'll just
kill themselves
they'll just die oh my gosh so good oh
my god
wow i honestly thought it was zombae
doing self reports i'm so sorry i had to
go for you zombae i'm so sorry i was
like i have to
it's just okay i have to do it okay okay
that was so close i so i didn't realize
how close the door was to like the o2
thing when i was murdering i was like i
gotta get at least one kill in
yeah i was like please help miranda but
oh my god honestly you guys were like it
was like two
three seconds from oxygen being done and
i was like they're just going to kill
themselves
i don't have to worry about it it's so
cool i was like i swear to god if we die
on sabotage right now i'm gonna be so
depressed
we've somehow already raised over two
thousand dollars
yeah somebody donated a full thousand so
we're i only set the goal at two
thousand five hundred
uh early twenty five minutes in that's
amazing thank you guys so much
uh i need to change some of the settings
the kill countdown is way too long
you make it this timer i can't get over
just toasted on your face
[Music]
that seems right well that seems good
all right all right
i'm really sorry especially zombae
though it was too easy and i'm really
sorry about it
it's too good does anyone have a
squad stream fired up oh should we
for some reason construction just
started in my building
what are you doing it's whoa it's 8 30.
why does that happen i don't know oh my
gosh it should not be happening um yeah
does anyone need any setups
things like that so question um i
realized i accidentally
um muted myself this whole time um
do you guys want to have a ghost room
for people to chat
yeah why don't you guys um just jump in
general oh yeah it's a good idea
yeah that's awesome it's optional
you don't have to if you want to like
take your time to like take a break or
whatever but like if you wanna i am
deafening myself every time so you guys
could potentially just
unmute just talk yeah yeah for myself
and i'm on fishing park
so yeah i am too well yeah we'll figure
out when you die you could do either
we'll abide by that um yeah has everyone
got their setup stuff done should i
should i
begin again yeah can't wait to not be
the imposter
god i'll be great i'm so sorry i just
you know
crewmate all right
okay i would like to not die which one
of you [ __ ] is it now i got to
be on the good team
mort if you could follow me if anyone
could follow me this is a visual task
you would see it
they might be too new to know that they
might be too new
[Music]
okay
she would have killed me already she was
gonna kill me
uh i feel like she's good i feel like
she's good
i did not get a ps5 sadly no
um i did also have to like fight so oh
hello i could i could put up a hundred
percent for zombo
because her and i walked into electrical
and found the body
okay where was the button electrical
apparently i can vouch for trish trish
did not do it
i can vouch for um steimer because we
were both just kind of standing there
for a bit
yeah alana and i were both in weapons
doing tasks and definitely could have
murdered each other trish did you see me
do the task by any chance i was like
she's played this game visual tosser on
hopefully she sees it did you see me
doing it i didn't
think visual tasks are on i just saw you
standing by the chair forever
it was like hopefully she looks but no
that's fine whatever we didn't kill this
okay so an electrical
doing tasks around uh electrical-ish
area
so i mean i can kind of vouch for their
presence okay
uh joey okay what's up i was in medical
yeah
that you're in medical see
all right well that's not much to go on
uh holly
i was by myself on the left side in the
beginning trisha saw me run left but i
was the only one i think that did that
and then i ran and saw uh zombae miranda
and steimer
running into electrical when i was
coming from the left okay so i guess
that does clear
the the zombae miranda uh yeah they
never never went to electrical someone's
with me
in the cafeteria i was in the cafeteria
first that i went down to
storage and then i was going to
electrical when the button was put
yeah and i saw her i saw her doing that
oh my god we're over three thousand oh
my gosh but one of your [ __ ] is a
murderer but thank you all so much for
three thousand dollars
yeah over three thousand dollars that's
amazing
thank you what uh i feel like skip vote
classic first round
okay okay bye don't kill me
okay i right now i'm actually saucy
brianna
because this is so stupid i could be
completely wrong
um just because of the way she asked the
question like solely because of the way
she said
uh where was the body
it was a um it was like the sound of
someone who knows you know
okay i kind of want to stick with trish
because then i think i would live
but maybe not the best idea i think
these [ __ ] is maybe something's up to
something
ariana hey hey hey
miranda miranda don't miranda no
miranda please not you
oh joey what the [ __ ] was that what is
any of this
oh my god
i didn't like that at all okay
that's these these murderers are bad
they're not they're not really
doing enough joey what the [ __ ] are you
doing why are you standing around like a
weird dude
i should do this shouldn't i just okay
it's timer
okay it's done cool that's cool joey
what what the [ __ ] are you doing joey
i think i should call a meeting on joey
like the vibes are bad man the vibes are
bad and i could be super wrong
but i just think she's being [ __ ]
suss
simon appears to be doing a task
holly okay everybody's walking away it's
gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
somebody's gotta be [ __ ] dead trish
is also fine
someone has to be dead i'm just gonna
call a meeting
oh crisis got it okay i've never called
one before you know
okay it was quiet for so long i know i
went to call an emergency meeting
because i was like some [ __ ] that's
right
it's joking so i was gonna call an
emergency meeting to report joey
yeah guys i found the dead body um in a
room and the last person i saw coming
out in the other direction was joey
joey you i was literally walking the
cafeteria to report joey because i felt
like you would walk in one direction and
then stop and then walk towards me and
then walk away
you were walking towards me was i was i
joey noel
two people for joey huh
exactly two people i found the body joy
was at the body
and then someone else's already i'm
really sorry from wrong
that is enough for me it's i'm confident
you do a body
i i'm sorry joey i like you we were not
doing a dance you were absolutely
walking towards me and then pausing at
that no it's totally hard and i'm so
sorry if i'm wrong but i'm super [ __ ]
confident
evidence as well there that's good [ __ ]
that's good [ __ ]
on your way out tell us who you think it
is joey yeah
no idea i know that it wasn't re because
she and i were together on the right
side
for a long time but other than that i
don't have any
good points does that mean it is free
how do you feel about being endorsed by
an impostor
here's the thing i would i would vouch
for joey but
so many people are saying they literally
saw her do it so
maybe she was marinating me i don't know
what does that even mean i don't know
afc explained it on the stream the other
night
well so i i think it's like that's
the thing i learned it from there too
but i think it's like when you're the
killer
you're keeping certain people alive as
you're allowed to trust you yeah
yeah that's you randy i will say alana's
doing a lot of accusing right now
well that's because you're that's
because you're a murderer so you know
gotta clean them out
my god
the task is still not done what the [ __ ]
i hope i'm right sometimes i get so
brutal with my accusations
but to be fair i think i only do it when
i'm super confident and i do know joey
pretty well as a human uh ah [ __ ]
yeah fix these [ __ ] lights fam
trish is totally clear we have no beef
with trish
she's fine i just have to do my taste in
comps for [ __ ] sake
who is that did i say mord i think
okay
yup
okay whoa what whoa oh no we checked out
joey it's just
it's just holly okay ran across holly's
body i was coming up from
store it's like the right side of the
map is that storage no
shield from caught like up heading over
to like navigation
uh okay um i saw nobody else though so
it's really not helpful i just ran and i
was like oh [ __ ] there's
there's a hamster is anyone not like so
i just paused trisha again i'm so
confident trisha is
is good i just saw him electrical with
everybody who was fixing the lights
who was anyone not in electrical
uh i just saw mod i was just
like guys it's miranda it's miranda
because rihanna and simon have been
doing tasks the whole time
i saw alana stuck behind the ball at the
door yeah and alana can voucher
trish was just above me okay if
miranda's the only one that's not there
is what i was trying to
calculate there yeah this is correct i
was also not there
but i did not see anybody else
so i don't i did not go to the right
side of the map for that time i was
around the upper engine in the med bay
and just kind of hung out the cafeteria
because i forgot to uh mute myself on
there and then i accidentally
changed my scene on obs so
i apologize i got a list sorry
i still have tasks and what are they i
have one task left and it's in
communications which is where i was just
trying to head where
my posture is and ran into more i have
one more in electrical i had two
that weren't electrical i have one more
in navigation but when the doors shut
in when the doors shut i was in the
upper engine so miranda when were you in
upper engine because i was
i do think look we could be wrong but
but the strat here is to identify where
we found everyone miranda you being
alone could be very unfortunate
but i gotta do it to you also just in my
own defense mods been very sketch
in accusing people um it's true i
don't know why people are targeting me
i've done all my tasks i've done all my
jobs
all i can do now is detect i feel like
we got them both here you guys
i think i literally don't know how to
crack my tasks aside from them being on
the left
yes
oh man that was miranda that was
that was like
wish i could like make it so you want
just use your map and just go to where
it says on the map
there was something else that i wanted
to change
hold on who who were the imposters on
that one joey and miranda
[ __ ] you and julia
i have to murder somebody really quick
oh my god
i don't know how to do this
yeah maybe i should add two we can
always change it yeah i would say it is
like really hard with so many people
like everyone's always bunched together
yeah which is fine
yeah you have to get someone isolated i
gotta get rid of my little pet because
when i get murdered my little pet's so
sad
i know it's so sad they just stay behind
i'm just gonna press
the hamster because i won't be able to
see how sad that oh i hit stop again so
hopefully you did it
okay yes i think we're good if not it's
all good
all right cool
cafeteria
interior cafeteria alligator
i watch a something something movie
theater
it's i don't i don't make that up this
one exists i swear
all right okay captain sabotage what are
you doing miranda
what are you doing why did you run out
of here zombie is somebody [ __ ] dead
in here no
it is weird to have o2 occur and then
leave
she can kill me
girl what are you doing what are you
doing
what are you doing what is happening
i don't uh
i kind of want to like follow what is
miranda doing though
why is miranda being like this
what is this weird behavior you people
have we're playing with too many new
people that's the problem
no no no i don't know
for sure i thought for sure holly was a
killer because she like
walked into the reactor room when i was
doing my task in there and then like
circled around and then like left and i
was like um that's suspect but she's
dead now so
i can vouch for steimer because i was
running around with steiner pretty much
this
the whole time we were like on the same
loop over to um
i would like to hear her voice when i
accuse this but the last person that i
saw holly bible with
quite recently was trisha
i just went from reactor i did the
reactor because of the sabotage
and then ran down who found the body
i did she's in electrical at the very
back and i feel like
i'm not positive but i feel like the
person i had seen come from that way
most recently was zombae and i think
joey came from there pretty recently
you guys came up through storage and
into that but i came from the right side
i didn't see where you came from i did i
did come up through there and i was
in admin finishing my test and there was
like a bunch of other people in there
there were a lot of people in admin yeah
everybody i was curious somebody when o2
went off you left the room where o2
would have been
like you could have you could have been
in there and done the thing but you left
when the
the thing went off was it o2 or reactor
i thought reactor went off
it was reactor too uh whichever it was
it was in the room because i went in the
room to do it and then i think i watched
someone else do it and you
you were peaceing out i was gonna say i
vouched for mod because mod and i were
the two that turned off reactor i think
there was one other person in the room
but i don't remember who else it was
it was holly bible who's dead yeah
i went down to where electrical is which
is where the body was and i went up to
medical
so i'm pretty confident
you went up to medical mod yeah i was at
the top oh that's right i saw you and i
did things look i'm just gonna say you
guys i am i'm
aggressively confident that zombae
a skipped doing a task and b came from
the area the body was in that's all i'm
gonna say
oh [ __ ] i it's usually i skip around but
i would just say
just watch out for us is all i'm saying
i'm watching voting right now
oh i tried to vote for her did my vote
[Music]
i think i'm right i think i'm right uh
uh is that people being stupid in my
chat is that what's happening
uh not that i can see
i can't see it but i also i don't care
i'm just trying to uh i will remove
people if they need to be timed out you
guys can basically just give me
usernames
and i can tell you who i need to get rid
of youtube
all the way around you can tell me who i
need to get rid of
okay
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] i think joey's good
i feel like miranda is has also been
weird but i think this is the first
round she's ever played
where she hasn't been a murderer
trish trish trish trish
trish am i being chased trish
where was that alana um the top
right of the map right underneath the oh
[ __ ] i was going near that
the the top right like weapons i mean
trish you basically just
followed me to where where i walked
which is where it was right below
weapons
oh i know okay steimer and i were both
[ __ ] around in like the
storage area electrical yeah we're in
electrical all three of us were in
electrical
miranda's on the other side so wait wait
wait who have we identified
i'm confident miranda and joey are good
actually right now yeah
we were over in med bay
to see her do tasks also because i
didn't know where i was going i didn't
know you could collapse
the task and he was like where are my
tests i did say on stream miranda i was
like miranda's behavior is weird but i
think it's because she's clearly just
discovering tasks for the first time
because this is her first round
i was like she's doing toughness i was
like oh this will be great and intuitive
i was like what the hell
anyway so joey and miranda have seen
each other trish was behind me for a
while there but i don't know when that
body got killed but trish was behind
as i ran up on it i went from lower
engine over to navigation to do a task
and like
half that run i was with alana yeah but
i don't know when the body died and i
feel confident rolling trish out
accountability wise um oh [ __ ] diamond
i can vouch morph this dimer than i can
zombae because diamond was there the
whole time and somebody ran in
i would also say vegeta steiner because
i saw her so many times while i was
fueling
and like is anyone vouching for rihanna
i've seen i mean she i saw her with me
um mod where were you right next to
steiner for like a while
we had to vote i saw mod run into
electrical
uh when i passed so there was some time
there but if mod says she was an
electrical i can
vouch for that and mod i'm still very
confident that somebody left a room
where a body died last time voting for
zombae
i'm sorry because i did you daddy lost
around but i think you're a murderer
oh yeah but it talks a lot i don't know
trish ran up
oh it worked okay well that happened i
didn't write i didn't
yeah you don't have to i think i think
we made it i think we did the right
thing i think we did i'm sorry you're
amazing but i think
i think i was right i think i saw her
walk away from the room
uh okay see i am doing a lot of talking
they're right
which appears to be sus but to be fair
uh
this one it's because i find the bodies
eight five six one enter
okay what do we got shields
i don't think it's moored i think that
mode would be more obvious if she were
lying
um i don't know about joey
oh that's right sorry it's not that task
is not that complicated
there's the one and the other one where
you have to tap the thing repeatedly
uh is there cameras in here just
communication
no okay
steima you running away from a body
rihanna what are you doing rihanna
rihanna
rihanna rihanna
she would have killed me right she would
have killed me
i feel like she would have killed me i
need to react okay
okay okay that's all i'm saying oh she
you hate to see it i got locked
i think i'm alone here though so
i have to pay a lot of attention to this
one
i was so close to being done i just
found a dead body in the cafeteria
oh well joe was with me in electrical
correct
and i don't think
steimer and joey down by like shields
and comms
i don't know how good it was engine and
then i came up through cafeteria
to finish my divert power task and i
found the body and connected
more do you just walk past me where i
was doing the task in electrical which
is one of the longer ones where you have
to press the button in the right order
and i was just saying to my chat that i
was on the the last one and i was like
for [ __ ] sake you called the meeting
when i was on the last button and now i
have to do it all over again
so that's where i was i was in you know
that'd be
incredibly frustrating when that
happened yeah i was like i was so close
to completing it
so as far as i've seen people doing
tasks this entire time
steimer i believe is fine joey i now
think is fine alana i think is fine
rihanna and trisha i'm suss
again well okay
this last one i was at shields doing a
task this
whole time so i know i wasn't near mod
but i have
joey and uh who else was there with me
trish what do you mean this whole time
the shields task is quite short
i will say that we were in comms for a
little bit and steiner was there by
herself
as we were trying to fix it when the
thing went off i tried to
do this [ __ ] cops
because it was the lang line wave one
right that one knife also oh
yeah i think when i'm back because
trisha kept going in when we had the
other emergency
is she going to kill steimer
and then someone else came up then after
that we went down into comms and then
over to shield i don't know trisha
what i don't i'm keeping my eye on you
yeah i think
i think that i don't know if we want to
vote trish right now but she's the one
that yeah let's do it
let's do it all right chaos i welcome
chaos so sorry
um because we've just made this game a
lot harder for ourselves if we're
if we're wrong but i i feel like she's
the only one that wasn't accounted for
the whole time
please please trish please otherwise
it's gonna be really difficult
we'll just
[Music]
why is everybody murdering me stop hold
on
really um
and i don't know how to do them and
they're way longer so i'm just standing
here like an idiot
i kept finding bodies and i was like i'm
a second away from them all thinking
it's me i swear to god
as soon as zombie walked into the room i
was like i'm doomed
[Laughter]
good game guys um yeah i intentionally
have ejections turned off because i
think it makes the game a little bit
harder
but yeah it's more exciting yeah
i felt good about that one it was good
that was fun we took some risks but it
was clean work
because nobody actually saw anything no
i'm gonna order pizza
dude good call what kind of pizza are
you getting
my usual zombae is that a flamingo
on your head wait what is that what are
you doing
so cute yeah i wanna hear what the usual
pizza is
oh um it's uh sausage and olives
i like pineapple i won't come at you i
love starting the rounds because now
we're talking about pineapple and i
don't want to hear it so now i have to
death
without being rude
okay
loves to not be a at a pasta loves it
huge fan of it
okay mod that's bit weird more
more
navigation okay this seems pretty legit
i literally just more no
come on come on come on
and then she went to uh shields and she
was dead
so whoever it was is a ninja
yeah that was so fast but like she was
with me
it was fascinating and doing some stuff
and she was also in the cafeteria with
me so we were nowhere near
that area who's on the right-hand side
of the map
i was literally like she's i wasn't i
was in electrical during my test i just
walked into the conference after i did
yeah
what are you going to say i are on the
left
i just want to say i'm not guilty and
don't throw me out the [ __ ] flap
but she's also the one who reported
that's all we're really close to
four thousand dollars that's all i'm
saying can anybody else see anybody else
it was scary guys she was there one
second and then she was gone the next so
who plays this game a lot and who is
expert level
trisha and you found it holly plays this
game
expert level shields but i feel like
after yeah but that's the only thing i
saw
i was like don't vote me just because i
played this game a lot of us please
i don't know it's i was on the left side
and zombies
okay i'm skipping yeah i didn't see
anyone so i skipped yeah
it's all mine and i don't think that's
enough to just
vote for who's saying that because i'll
hang with you if you'd like
oh no no it's fine i mean it's just
that's like literally the only person i
saw on the right side of the map but
i don't feel like that's enough to just
vote
good luck y'all [ __ ] dead i can't
believe it i can't believe they've done
this to me
i kind of want to follow trish like we
tend to we don't tend to finish the
tasks like
we tend to have chaos and shoe before we
finish any tasks so let me just find
i don't know who the other murderer is
andrea definitely trish
joey
is that trisha's strat like she just
like waits nia oh
i don't know who did it again
so fast dude okay so i was just doing
i was just doing the task with mod in
storage
and then i decided to go finish my tasks
in electrical
and then i saw the oxygen depleting so i
ran
which bt dubs both tricia and joey
made no moves to go down do the
emergency oxygen depletion i was
finishing my task i had one more wire
left
so um there's a possibility
it well i guess it couldn't have been
one of them because i was just with mod
so they're clear
because they were in the other room i'm
dead oh yeah it's okay
no no no no no not mod i mean joey thank
you yeah i was going to say i can vouch
i didn't actually
see i was going to come through yeah
[Music]
the reactor melting down everybody has
to go to the top
i kind of like to get my tasks done yeah
but if we don't
save ourselves that we all die the two
australians died
before so i know i'm a ghost but i just
think you guys should consider
storage whoever is motoring as a
xenophobe and is killing only
australians thank you bye
[Laughter]
we're we're safe because
okay so uh andrea did you say where you
found the body again i'm sorry
in storage in storage okay
because where was everybody else yeah
kenneth are you over moderating
i got rid of one of the other mods right
because he just keeps
are i expanded i haven't really caught
you yes but i haven't talked yet so
uh i was walking over to electrical
because i got a late start
um and then i was starting to go over to
the o2 as soon as that rang
well i guess we don't really have much
to do here oh zombie went
she's like dang okay
[Laughter]
sometimes
trish you got a deafened so i could talk
and zombie i guess
i don't know if you could hear it i
wanted to talk about hey
but i don't know if somebody can hear us
what the hell
she doesn't ran out okay it was miranda
oh it was miranda trish miranda's had it
so many times
oh my god when you found me i was like
trish killed me so fast but i i you were
in the same area that i was like oh
maybe she would have seen us like go
fast like maybe that would have happened
and i was like please i've seen it
did she go in the vents uh
no no she i think walked up and then she
was sitting in the room doing the task
so i was like oh she's clear she's doing
a task it'll be fine
oh my gosh yeah then she [ __ ] sniped
me
oh my god are you following miranda yeah
i want to see what she's up to
yeah miranda's sash she got me but she's
such a sweet girl like honestly one of
the sweetest people i know so miranda
having to go through this
what did it time out
that's why she wasn't doing the task
because she wanted us to die
how did you guys do that joey and i made
the hugest circle trying to get to the
ocean
i took a wrong turn should i turn the
timers up on those
that seems real short oh my god
i did a bad thing by watching for
miranda important to everybody
i did not realize that happened
imposter three times i know miranda i'm
so sorry
it's so stressful i don't know if i can
turn the timer up for
i did i did learn how to spot where my
fake tasks are
do that so that's good yes yeah
next
was nuts because i was like oh she's
doing a task i'm safe this is going to
be fine and then she [ __ ] murders me
as soon as i try to do it
she was just standing there and i was
like no
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you everyone what are we up to
four thousand we have four thousand two
hundred thirty five and fifty cents
that's so great also rihanna i don't
know if you saw but uh blair harder who
i don't know maybe is your boss
is at least an exactly yeah donated and
said g4 loves rihanna which i thought
was very oh
oh thanks claire that's so sweet
so i don't know if i can turn the
emergency like
it's not emergency cooldown that's not
right um the timer
for the the losing to the task
sabotages yeah yeah you can't change
that you can't change it okay
no there's no setting for it got it i
love that a couple of it's happened to
us twice
or almost this is so close that's why
you should not play like me
and always do your tasks instead of
getting the sabotage you should always
go and fix that
yeah i always try to have a balance
but i i did not expect that round to go
that way i was excited to watch miranda
because i was like i know she was kind
of newer what's her
what's her murder strat like what's
gonna happen here
pink again you guys want anything i'm
way it's way easier for me to lie when
i'm looking at people
that's
[Laughter]
all right i did not think that was going
to happen
uh what was i saying i feel like i i
started saying moderation policy for
youtube just so you guys know
generally don't care what you say about
me um
what i care about more you've been good
for so long
is that even a task there you know
i [ __ ] knew it i was like that's not
a task
oh it is though i saw nothing i was
still in the cafeteria ordering
and saw miranda's carcass and joey was
leaving the room
oh there was no that seems pretty
damning to me
i can confirm that joey was leaving
admin because i was just going in
joey what was he going to do
[Laughter]
okay
[Laughter]
i do say man you gotta go down fighting
joey you
joey i love you so much can i just throw
that out there
i love you so much joey as soon as you
walked in i was like oh
i cool down i can't kill trisha either
because i was thinking i was gonna do it
and then i was like well
that's hilarious double kills is that
like both of the imposters have to be
together at the same time to do that
yeah no
no no they could just do it
um ryan i just said when you were being
shitty um kenneth
basically just don't let people attack
each other murder fools
that's pretty much it it depends
sometimes like i don't really care about
what they say about me obviously i
wouldn't want
harassment that like destroys the whole
chat when people are rude or whatever
so alana was also dead there so there
was some funky stuff going on
more and more required that's gonna be
hotel mod was really quiet
everybody deafened so i can talk
to joey oh hey what's up cause what did
joey i sort of missed that because i was
home from my chat
hello oh you're all so dead that's right
i got i got guys
oh my gosh miranda i'm so sorry it's
okay it was really funny i was like oh
so you can stack on top of each other to
do your tasks
okay the stat kills are really good
they're really good like any time that
i've gotten one of those it's like super
satisfying
i feel like i've learned so much about
how
to fake doing tasks and like what you
need to do to say oh well i couldn't see
the map because
this task took up so much of my screen
like that's something that i didn't take
into account because i just haven't
i've played like only one real game as
like a crew member
my second yeah and so it's kind of funny
yeah it's so brutal that you got those
so fast like the the
imposters was like oh miranda but she's
so nice oh no
it's so hard to lie when you don't know
how to lie about these things
i mean look i hate lying like i'm i like
even for compliments like i want lighter
people to the extent that it can like
kind of be a problem and i need to be
better about it but
um i what i do to lie
is just actually tell the truth just
omit the murder part
so i just go like oh well i was here and
then i walked to here
um i did this task i saw this person so
like i just still tell the truth because
i am
not a good liar at all like the minute
that someone would be like alana i saw
you out of them i'd be like no
when you did the first game
you're really fast at killing people
like finding opportunities for that and
that's like
the hard part for me is just seeing when
people will be alone
like i think that that one in half
pretty well but
then someone walked in and i almost was
able to vent but
didn't get to because it i didn't
realize how like close the hallways were
there and so
yeah i used to never vent at all because
i was like well i take the chance but
you do have to kill quickly yeah that's
really what i should have done with you
right so yeah joey what happened there i
was talking to my chat did they just
like 100 percent
cat sheath yeah
oh hello welcome to dead land somebody
else has died
yeah it was me mod got again
yeah same dude i think she's working
with holly
it's uh is it not joey
it was definitely neat yeah oh yes
that's right it's just more now which
means like the win
is going to be is going to be pretty
tough yeah
um but i know it'll be easy to tell and
then
mod just or then trisha just walked in
yeah
i think uh i think if we listen to more
in these next few rounds i think she'll
be she's usually kind of loud i think
she'll be very quiet
and i think that's what her imposter
tell is going to be as she won't say
very much
oh my gosh no i was going to vouch for
zombae
is not it because i saw her doing a task
she did med bay yeah you found the body
i found it i was where was it i think oh
wait you just walked past me
i just walked past you we were walking
down yeah security right we're like the
engine we're like over by the engines in
the reactor
reactor area uh yeah oh it was so close
to 5 000 i saw my tasks and i thought it
was quiet so i was like i'm gonna look
around and then
i found her body but i didn't i wasn't
rihanna well it's being around there but
she was like up top
of electrical and then she's pretty
accusatory because she's small
and i found her body so i didn't see
anybody else around because i think i do
too
like i get very show look when i'm a
crewmate
purity i believe is the room yeah
because she was she was on fam
when i left her but that was a long time
ago too
thank you screwdriver mod where were you
we have nearly doubled the goal i was up
in that
cafeteria heading into navigation but
like i feel like i've been
putting out fires this whole time come
on come on now yeah you've been killing
people i passed by a lot were
ree steimer and mod and i don't
remember seeing trisha a lot even though
i want to get like real detail but if
i because i both trisha and i saw zombae
do
medpay true if i were imposter and i'm
not
i promise like that's the thing that you
do in your posture you kill the person
that's
innocent because then there's one less
hmm
you know innocent person too yeah i
thought i've seen holly doing tasks i've
been redoing capcom yeah i've seen
steimer
in hollywood i haven't seen him a couple
times
we do have to vote someone because
otherwise [ __ ] i just have to
imposter last time mod throwing shade
oh my god i love you oh my god
[ __ ] what does that mean good it's so
tense
are you wrong did i overthink it
we [ __ ] up didn't we exactly what she
was witnessing
well
hey ghosties hey ghosts
um yeah if you can hear us you better
deafen yourself we see you i think
everyone
has yep everyone else is dead
um trish that was [ __ ] brutal totally
you totally called mod being quiet in
that round yeah i know right she's way
way way more quiet than she normally is
i was like oh trish you know her
surely you can tell that it's hard she's
being quiet
i definitely knew it was mod and mod's
defense is always to blame trisha
so the second she's like a second she's
like oh man it must have been trish i
was like it's mod hands down
yeah i was like because i she
she's definitely like loud and i was
saying it's because she's smart like
it's because she
could figure out what's happening she's
like gets to sleuthing you just talk a
lot when you get in that
in that space like she knows what's
going on and she wants to vocalize it
but i was like if she's impossible she's
going to be [ __ ] quiet and that's
exactly what happened
what was that you gotta tell come on
come on
also my poor little hamster i'm sorry to
leave you
i don't know what's going to happen here
because oh
okay oh my god that was so stressed out
at the reactor
no one would put their hand on the other
thing
so actually i think that it's that it's
mode i think that the tone
oh no oh god what's happening who called
the meeting
me i'd uh holly you think it's mine i
think it's mod because
i a couple reasons like we one of you
i think it was timer we were watching
her do the task
in navigation but the task bar didn't go
up and then the emergency started
and then she also ran up to the top left
of that room for some reason
but then she didn't go to the event
because we were there obviously but then
uh let me randomly it's not dimer
because we've been howling around this
whole game
well and you two were already in the
reactor i think on one of them and then
when i was running to reactor i came a
little bit late because i ran
up to like fake i was going up and then
i went down to make sure she didn't kill
a steimer
um and when i was coming up to reactor
from the bottom
she wasn't like in a hurry ticket to
reactor
um that's all i i could be wrong but i
don't think i am
ever i'm pretty sure we were all there
when the reactor was going off and we
were all defusing it
no come on come on holly come on come on
oh
that was amazing i love it no you aren't
[Music]
me that time like all forget that i'm
the one that got joey in the beginning
oh my god oh yeah everybody a hundred
percent forgot about that oh i forgot
oh true true um that was the closest
task i've ever had be completed like the
wire for sabotage
oh my god guys i've eaten far too much
food with this nervous while gaming my
hands were shaking
my heart was going so fast i [ __ ]
hate being the imposter it is
the worst
yeah i didn't know you almost hadn't
thought way cooler
oh
so that's the best thank you everyone uh
that round was incredible and i just
want to say that uh one of my favorite
among us moments of every time i've ever
streamed is now rihanna saying no you
want
timing on that was so good hi
good luck
okay you should probably do another map
soon in it
probably okay
i'm gonna know when it's more now that's
the thing what are you doing
okay there's enough of us here that will
be fine also this is a visual task
i don't know how it works though
but i think that like in theory maybe
it's not maybe you can't see that one i
know you can see the one at the bottom
but maybe not that one
sniper don't don't do me dirty please
timer please leave please
[ __ ]
okay andrea andrea
now she's gonna be suss of me based on
what that just happened holy [ __ ]
oh my god oh when that first popped up i
was like
no andrea has killed me because i
thought i know
[Applause]
oh my god same same i literally jumped
i really thought i was gonna die because
i was going to fix the wires and i did
not realize that was a multi-part task
and i was like wait why is it directing
me to the cafeteria and i was like
oh and then i went to um the security
room and as soon as i was walking toward
that area
the doors closed behind me i was like oh
no and then the screen flashed up and it
wasn't me
okay so we trust miranda holly what's up
i'm learning
who found the body well um i saw rihanna
kill trish on
oh you electrical it happen um okay
okay great great
i mean she's right
[Laughter]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my gosh um she's right amazing i love
you
what the hell am i voting for oh
definitely rihanna
100 rihanna i'm sorry rihanna
i know that black girls stick together
i'm so sorry well she's a moderator
[Laughter]
[Music]
she'll she'll dub you in that's the
situation uh rihanna do you want to vote
for someone just so we can i'm going to
skip
[Music]
i don't think anyone is suspicious
amazing oh my gosh amazing
oh god my face hurts from laughing
that doesn't happen that often on
streams um okay
maud was quiet there but i actually
don't think it's her this time but she
was quiet in that one to the extent that
i could have been like
come on garrett i picked up on your
[ __ ]
the problem is like i feel like holly's
the dark horse when it's her we're not
gonna [ __ ] have any idea cause she's
too good
[Music]
okay
it's in here electrical style please
stymous
timer please sniper that's a bit weird
more
that's a bit weird the [ __ ] is that
what is she doing what task is even on
there
mort i did just say i didn't think she
was suss
and then that [ __ ] happens hey
miranda what's that
miranda miranda you can't be doing that
[ __ ]
miranda stop chasing me oh my gosh
miranda [ __ ] off miranda
stop it miranda leave miranda go away
miranda no
miranda go away go away
i'm gonna go report you is what's gonna
happen here
i'm just gonna [ __ ] go nope nope nope
no we got report better we gotta we
gotta [ __ ] do it
we have to go and we have to report
miranda
but whatever the [ __ ] that just was
[Laughter]
what were you doing there's no way
there's no way come on
um what happened
miranda what the [ __ ] what are you doing
i was trying to do my
toss i was being followed i locked
myself in the corner of a room because i
felt like i was being hunted
i was like what are you why are you
standing there why didn't you go
elsewhere
timer's attention there's no tusk in
that room miranda
i could do this so here's the thing i
also
noticed miranda acting very suspiciously
but i have to imagine
it's got to be impossible for her to
have drawn imposter again
that would be uh weird foreign
i said what were you doing six times no
i was following you because i'm trying
to stay in groups of two or three of
people that i trust i did say previously
when you detailed the task i was like
she's gotta be innocent
that was so weird you were being weird
i like her and i the doors were locked
when i was trying to go up um
okay what is that the engine room to the
cafeteria that was locked
and her and i crossed paths right there
i went to the
um cafeteria to do like a thing
and now she's dead on the screen so i
don't know where her body is
but she was headed toward med bay slash
the engines and now she's
done so and that's like the area i saw
alana miranda all those folks in
okay so it's possible that it's miranda
again
no no no no no no no no no no listen
listen to me though oh i can't scared of
alana because she did not hide by the
cameras
she was hiding by the vent correct
because i thought you were going to kill
me so here's what i can't say
we are in security what i can say is
miranda and i can account for each other
that whole round
because we were so suspicious of each
other miranda did not do any murdering
but she may still be i saw steiner all
past me as well so
no no this this is super suspect for
both of you now because
i saw miranda alone so you couldn't have
been with each other the whole time
i mean maybe not but all i know is that
i got very heated and brands
i literally ran to another room because
i panicked that miranda was gonna
[ __ ] kill me
i just didn't want to be alone oh wait
zombie why don't you go holly for holly
somebody
i don't give a [ __ ]
oh my gosh he's a murderer all the time
i don't care
i don't think she ever has been oh god i
think miranda
we may have just like had social
awkwardness there it may have
legitimately been nothing but it was
[ __ ] weird i was just trying to avoid
her
[ __ ] that's funny okay
she might legitimately be fine oh
okay joey joey joey
come on holy [ __ ] i didn't [ __ ]
suspect that i didn't see that coming
look at the body it's just up there
holly look up styler holly
dybalastic style who's the other one
look up oh my god they just keep running
past yeah you if no one ever has to go
there they'll never find me
i'm dead here forever now that's a good
kill spot
oh my god yeah so we do tasks
yeah i'll keep doing it yeah finish your
tasks
that i so i assume that miranda is
actually innocent and that we just did
something very socially awkward and
didn't realize what happened
oh we've been really quiet yeah your
favorite kill spot again
did you do it again yeah in electrical
oh
oh my god no one's looking
miranda miranda you didn't see that oh
my gosh
she's [ __ ] going for it miranda look
out
look up i play okay okay
hello hello i saw joey venting
i was finishing my task at security
because i finally did the little wire
thing because i was too scared to go
over there because i was like man people
know i still haven't done this
okay so you saw her come out of the vent
i saw her come from the corner
for sure corner of which one from the
vent
absolutely yes miranda where were you
last then joey
sorry uh i was in security
sorry yes and how where did you come
from before that i was an electrical
i came all the way did you vent because
i
definitely saw you from the vet if you
saw her vent
like you could you could you swear you
saw her
okay i'm voting for joey i don't know
i came from electrical it came through
lower engine it's not a good deal
at one point because the door closed and
i freaked out that i was gonna die and
then i didn't
and then went to store right because
then storage
then storage also closed and there is a
big
people there we also yeah because we
were all stuck there because the doors
got shut
alana's dead right is that yes is that
you apparently
i think that's new it's not then it's
definitely
oh [ __ ] it might be miranda pretty good
i didn't see anybody
because miranda and alana were the two
suspicious ones and now alana's dead
oh and i voted for joey i can't take my
vote back
jumping came from the vent i don't know
the other one yeah it sounds like
something an imposter would lie about
literally it's all i popped up from the
vet do you guys think i suddenly got
good at lying at this game because i
don't know
i don't think i'm skilled enough to do
that though i appreciate the
zombies my thoughts were i had my
head down was doing my [ __ ] [ __ ] i
honestly was vibing and didn't really
care what happened
uh so i can't let you vouch for me or
vouch for anybody else y'all just gonna
have to
buy this one out well no but what do you
how do you feel about the evidence
that's been presented i feel like it's
always
holly oh i don't know
i voted i'm just kidding
to me it took me a while and i was like
i don't know
but we'll find out
[Music]
[Laughter]
is that trisha walked by me and i was
like oh do i go back and kill her and
then like 10 seconds later
rihanna killed her i'm so sorry you did
really good though i didn't realize
it was really good i was so weird
[Laughter]
like two people walked through the room
that joey killed me in and nobody
realized
it was just it was in cafeteria because
she walked in one
afternoon didn't see [ __ ] no one noticed
that i died nobody they were like oh
who's new
honestly
a lot quieter but i'm mostly just
concerned that i'm being accused
andrea i have to say i'm disappointed in
you for not noticing that i died i'm
sorry
i'm sorry i didn't notice that you were
dead i
died yeah you're right
i did i told you i didn't i did you
dirty
i need to pay better attention to my
friends
i did not realize it was rihanna i
thought it was just
uh like joey and then i was like who the
[ __ ] is the other person i have no clue
i couldn't figure it out
my gosh spicy that one was quick i feel
like
all right we're going again
that was great also zombae that last
it was holly but then you're like i'm
just kidding
good [ __ ]
okay i will change the map next time
let's go
i feel like there are like a couple of
people who haven't been impossible i
don't think holly has
i don't think andrea has i don't think
it's beautiful i wasted it again though
i shouldn't have done that because
someone can spot me doing that one
and it didn't happen but get the [ __ ]
get the shitty leaves out of the [ __ ]
ship
how do they even get here there's no
tree in the ship i don't know how this
happened
done uh we can go down to comps shall we
just down
to calms also seriously we're almost at
six thousand this is amazing you guys
thank you
this is um for anyone who's just joining
us we're raising money for black girls
code
which is basically a program that
teaches uh girls from seven to seventeen
how to program it's pretty rad they uh
also do a lot of work in
um uh communities that need help
basically
all right yeah
um the link is in the description on my
youtube and then in the like panels
thing i don't [ __ ] know what it's
called or how it works
on twitch okay what are you guys doing
down there just hanging out
doing a task is that what's happening or
okay nobody's found a dead body yet
stamina why are you spending so long
just standing there stymo
what are you doing andrea
andrea andrea andrea please andrea
please don't kill me
no she did it okay okay
thank you
um have i been impasta ac mike
yes trish
trish nope everything's fine i think i'm
gonna get all my talks done how is
nobody
dead like what has happened
this doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
oh about time
yeah man all right oh mod and miranda
oh no we acknowledge
[Laughter]
she was in the hallway uh mod was in the
hallway i should say i don't know where
miranda is
where was the body found in the hallway
trish you were with me but it was like
before if you just kept going up
trish you would have okay okay i saw a
bunch of people in electrical just now
as i was going past storage over to the
navigation side
i forget who it was though i feel like i
saw everyone
yeah i do too i did not see you at any
point holly i did
i saw trisha and i can definitely vouch
for steimer because she and i had a lot
of the same tasks
and i'm also gonna say andrea you were
in a room with me
with ample time to kill me and didn't
and i was scared and then you didn't so
i was like yeah she's probably fine
the only sus person so far for me is
zombae because she like walked into a
room and then like
dipped out real quick and i will also
say that rihanna was suspicious because
i walked by
somebody maybe it was miranda in storage
you missed your button you stopped
pressing your button again joey you
gotta hit that button down
zombae zombae voted pretty quick um yeah
so i voted
and then i could see miranda on the
other or miranda on the other side
and re doubled back to come towards me
and then when she saw miranda kept going
the other way so that seems kind of
suspicious
so i was confused okay um
i don't feel like we have anything to go
off so i'm going to skip skipping is
for choice suspicious that miranda's
dead now though where miranda's body is
it could have been
i was in storage so no you're the only
one who hasn't voted
was it me
[Music]
i trust you i think maybe holly this
time
i think zombie's fine um
i don't know why i think that though
like i don't have any grounds to think
that but i'm like
feeling some [ __ ] about
oh i've done all my [ __ ] toss i have
to find someone i trust and stay with
them then
my tasks are all done i don't know who i
trust holly
holly holly holly holly holly what are
you doing holly
olly don't kill me okay there's two of
you there's two of you there's two of
you
those two cool i think holly just did
that actually
who do i trust andrea
yes i'm hanging out with you andrea what
buds i'm not going to kill you i'm
literally intentionally following you
no i trust zombie as well i trust the
three of you is my point here i just
want you to know this is happening
because i like you and i don't think
you're going to kill me
i'm not gonna you don't have to run away
from me i would have murdered you if i
were gonna murder you andrea don't run
to the report button
this is happening because i trust you
the [ __ ]
what were you doing zombae huh what were
you doing
oh first of all y'all were being creepy
little weirdos
so we got murdered somebody murdered
simon
best with me i would like to speak about
what i believe is that uh i trust andrea
and i finished all my talks so i was
like i'll just follow andrea
what could go wrong and i was like is
andrea gonna report me i don't know
i finished all of my tasks as well and i
was like zombae is the one that i'm
suspicious of so i'm gonna go follow her
around
i just i only think why weren't you
doing your tests before
or something why aren't you look andrea
to be clear we were basically stalking
her but i think the three of us are fine
like i think genuinely if we just stick
together
we're all together because you guys were
all my ass the entire time
guys with us
i have new evidence to throw into this
too okay so
uh the doors were shut into electrical
and as soon as they opened i found
steimer's carcass at the bottom of
electrical
uh so i didn't see anyone walk in or out
but i didn't have time to report steimer
because you called the emergency meeting
just as i was about to do it
did you see anything but there's also a
vent
in and out of electrical so it's very
possible somebody vented
out of that room can everyone just
mention that steima was killed can we
all just acknowledge
rip rip dimer was moted okay
uh was anyone nearby did you see
anything trish i was added to navigation
before we started i was coming from
reactor went down through lower engine
and then the door to electrical shut
which i was like
that's suspicious there's probably a
dead body in there so i waited until the
door opened and sure enough there was
timer right on the other side
so holly where were you yeah i was just
in cams but
i didn't see anything all i saw was you
guys following each other around
did you go to cams from the vent from
electrical
no i did not madam i walked there with
my own two feet
i like the use of jogging that makes me
[Music]
that's all right it's all right i still
think it's holly i'm just gonna [ __ ]
stick with andrea again
you know i'm just sticking with andrea
we are staying together
she's not a murderer you know that's
what's up
andrea let's okay can we just buddy up
please andrea
andrea stop trying to evade me what's
happening
trish okay well we could just hang out
three yeah okay can we like maybe go
somewhere i feel like we want to look at
oh someone is on camps okay okay okay
i love this game holy [ __ ]
oh okay who did that rihanna
rihanna joey
okay cool i'm not
seeing holly was going to come and
mutter me that i think
zombie's fine holly's just running along
zombies running off to holly
oh he's coming back nothing okay okay
well then
well i mean it's holly right like
charlie like
why we like one of you would have left
right like okay if we have joey
me andrea trish who's left
i feel like
i feel like we could just go [ __ ]
report some [ __ ] here
oh oh it's an electrical damn it damn it
damn it damn damn
you gonna stay with me please yeah let's
go let's go let's go i feel like it's
[ __ ] holly but
sure like there's just no way
it's okay okay rihanna did do that okay
hmm i tr if i trust these four that's
oh oh
[Music]
oh that's what i thought yeah when we
had the four of us that was like well
then we just go report hollywood
right i just got reported ollie is a
raggedy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i did kind of chase zombie down in the
cafe
100 was running away from me i know that
i'm so sorry i mean
holly you are mad sauce and when the
stack like of people was like walking
around in a circle it was trish
me um it was andrea and then joey as
well i was like well it's it's
rihanna and holly isn't it like what are
they gonna what are they gonna do like i
don't understand
why i couldn't do anything like what's
me rihanna killed me in cold blood
really quickly but holly was in the next
room and i'm like oh holly will find my
body this is great cool
and then run past my course we did make
that hard by sticking together and when
we were all on cams and
holly like you walked in the room and
then you left i was like well
you know that's a bit strange you like
just scoped it out and then bounced i
was like
come on i got lost actually i
i do that a lot because i need to
memorize colors of like where everyone
is and who's with who
so i do do that sometimes i think uh my
most brutal deaths so far the few times
i've been the crewmate
have definitely been from holly and
trish like you get locked in the room
suddenly they're like oh
god i'm so sorry because i knew you were
the only one that came in so i was like
i gotta i gotta close these doors i
gotta do it
closed doors captioning not available
good stuff i was very funny just
watching people like follow each other
and i love that there was a feud with
the andrea and zombie
but it was just that we were all
innocent and done just like i don't know
i know i wanted to just team up and be
friends and then we all started walking
around together and i guess
cracking up the whole time it was a fun
round
okay okay
[Music]
i haven't been imposter in such a long
time and it feels really [ __ ] good
that's all i'm saying
that was a nice nice clean work there i
will say
the biggest difference between like i
usually play this game with dudes
because like i guess
uh most of the streamers i know who
would ask me to do this with just guys
for some reason
um and the one thing in my own behavior
that has changed
is that if i suspect one of the women i
don't just outright say it
and i don't know why that's a that's uh
some kind of cultural thing but like
more andrea um
if i think it's one of them i don't go
bruises starts as [ __ ]
whereas
with uh the girls i'm like
i'm pretty suspicious of you but i don't
say it in front of everyone for some
reason i don't know why i don't know why
uh i thought it was there okay it's just
the gas thing
cool let's do it
okay all right what what
okay you know
what you did you know what you did
andrea it was andrea
andrew what's happening
what's happened andrew totally came out
of the event in navigation
that definitely sounds like something
that's somebody who murdered somebody
but somebody else agreed with me
somebody else
somebody else
[Music]
i was so excited i was the imposter so
excited
and then i just [ __ ] it up oh amazing
great good don't get caught i think it
was
actually that popped up like i'm a randy
and um she saved me
from being miss you
[Laughter]
i don't think we have enough evidence
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay thank you trump strike testicle who
hasn't showered in 19 days should i
shout you the same person who always
asked me that or is that a meme
um you haven't showered in 19 days
my answer depends on if you have a bidet
four nine seven seven eight um yeah we
did it okay
you guys better [ __ ] be going for the
other one i swear [ __ ] god you stupid
are you serious it's so slow
you [ __ ] [ __ ] okay um
yeah if you don't have a bidet you
should probably shower more frequently
than every 19 days like if there are
people around you you should be socially
conscious
of that i think um because you will
definitely smell after that amount of
time
um but generally it's not actually joey
oh oh no mod oh no
two people oh steimer was with me near
nav
yes and then i was just a reminder you
you voted me out
that's what happened oh oh oh yeah we
did objective
was clearly doing the trash and she got
[ __ ] murdered
but the trash with the bottom of the map
the one by uh like comms
sorry wait wait wait where did you find
one's body was bottom
storage
and then i was running over to go to
electrical and her body was just there
so i didn't see anybody else around
joey and i were both yeah joey and i
were both in electrical
i was admin but nobody was around
yeah i was at mid bay nobody was in
there
we'll say that when i was doing with dan
holly just kept looking at me when the
uh the o2
reactor i don't remember what went off
she was just looking at me and i just
kept there waiting that's
really interesting that you say that you
were doing the scan
scan's a visual joey um was what what
what kind of scanning
scan thing yeah so did you see how doing
it i was doing my electrical thing
what wait what holly are you saying you
didn't see the scan i'm confused oh yeah
sorry who was doing this game was
rihanna was saying it or
i was in med bay i was doing the little
okay sorry not you i thought joey was
saying she didn't skip and i was like
no joey 100 just said that joey 100 just
said she was doing
joey was standing on it when i was
that's why i was watching her in med bay
but she wasn't doing it okay it's chewy
no way that no way that's a visual task
visual tosser on joey
i think you just accidentally played
yourself and didn't realize that you'd
done it
congratulations you played yourself you
didn't have to say anything joey you
would have been fine
i'm trying so hard joey
are we right i was like joey no you
can't take the stand
in mid bay is like the one unfake oh
right oh my god
jelly disgrace
i wasn't even gonna bring it up but then
you brought it up
does that mean played with visual tasks
on oh i can turn them off if you guys
like let's
we can do that uh so that means the only
person who actually got murdered that
round is maude
everyone else lived that was half tidy
like how tight it was
no i killed miranda oh you're right
miranda did sorry [ __ ]
just because the only ghost i saw there
was more hang on let me turn visual
tasks off just for the
i've never played with visual tasks on
i'm going to take my head
off sorry joey yeah joey that sucked
that was not good work what's this
um can i change them okay that's pretty
cool
i've turned them off so we don't have to
see them but can i change the map here
or
we have to change rooms okay you have to
change rooms if you're going to change
them up
we can change rooms though okay let me
bail i'm making you one okay everybody
because i wanna i wanna buy some new i
wanna buy some new pets anyway if anyone
wants to go to the bathroom or anything
and do that right now that'd be cool
that'd be great yeah i might grab
the time to do it the more better time a
little
i'm gonna just have a few words in the
mirror we also hit
six thousand dollars so
oh my goodness that's exciting wow thank
you everyone
[Music]
do you guys think i should do three
imposters or leave it at two and i
need to lose a few pounds
have you played with three possibilities
a few times
for goofy ass
i'm down to experiment with the game
mode i can change some [ __ ]
so we can do we can do shorter times
let's do that
everything's shorter um
sounds good i'm helping the impulses a
little bit but i do feel like we're
pretty equal right now so let's
uh um i can't change the sabotage yeah
thanks everybody there we go i think
we're all right i just changed a couple
of things
what time uh what do the other maps look
like i've never played anything other
than this
this one is an outdoor map is the one
that i chose um which is an interesting
one because it has so much open space
i've never played either it's really
oh yeah i put a new code in discord oh
okay
yeah love you mod
you're doing great mods was being
positive
and encouraging in my chat oh i thought
you said maude but
are you saying mod i can't tell in the
american accent if you're saying moored
or mod
oh yeah it sounds the same as the same
mod
m-a-u-d got it got it morn
m-a-w-d maud
mode i've seen uh some [ __ ] disasters
with your name on
starbucks cups mode oh my god just like
atrocious
like they're like what what are you what
is this one that you're saying to me
i'll say it once and then stare at them
so that they can't ask again
you make intense like break out of sweat
i've been nod i have been um
oh what was that there's one last year
that was just
so far off thank you i was mom
i saw mom yeah good [ __ ]
that's bizarre
um i spell that though mod
[Laughter]
sounds like the residue of a bunsen
burner or something
i feel like sometimes they hear your
name and then they start writing they
they write m and they're like oh i don't
i don't know and they just make it up
all right all right has anybody played
with the kill distance longer
oh it's so hard yeah it's yeah it makes
it too easy for the imposters
oh okay even killed us since normal
sometimes
is like you can be like three bodies
like three crewmate bodies lengths away
from someone and still get them
oh wow
oh yeah
and thank you to the top donator the
imposter who donated a thousand dollars
that's ridiculous that's amazing oh
thank you that's incredible that is
incredible
good kind of imposter the goal was two
and a half thousand
and it's at six thousand one hundred and
forty nine dollars and fifty cents
y'all are amazing snaps
heck to the yes um lots of people in
our chat are commenting on how funny the
post-it
note on steimer's face is so good
oh i'm so dope
it's too late at night to be using power
tools yeah
friday night's going off hell yeah
it's like what are they making i don't
know my chat is going full
yay girls are doing it girl power girls
get it done
yeah i disagree i think women are
overrated um
and should stay in the kitchen
personally so yeah
i respect that um are we all here or did
holly
uh we're ten out of ten we're in sorry
just wanted to make sure you didn't yeah
guys so please let's do it i've never
done the other map
so you should be all right it's not too
hard oh yeah i've never seen this one
i had to pull up that wiki
i [ __ ] hate it
got to pretend to do this toss for
anyone who happens to know
holly watched that pretty intensely
i think
i i i gotta remember that my vision is
more than their vision that's the thing
which is like pretty [ __ ] [ __ ]
i hate this a lot and i really [ __ ]
hate it
we could do double kill no too many of
them
oh it didn't make oh it was gonna be
like it didn't make noise for me well of
course it didn't of course it didn't
what you doing zombie are you out here
putting in work
ah heck oh heck ah well zombie's done
that in it
so
i feel like holly's already being weird
about me and i don't know why hang on
um you could pretend to do that all but
[ __ ]
but i feel like her behavior is strange
[ __ ] i don't know what to do
i'm so nervous i [ __ ] hate this [ __ ]
so much
she is on me she is on my dick
i could totally have been caught just
there like holy [ __ ] that was bad
what am i supposed to do like oh that
was not a good call
i [ __ ] that up so bad i hate this the
most i hate it i hate it i hate it i
hate it i hate it
do we just pop out here just take the
rest go done okay bye
i killed the person who i felt was
suspicious of me
and then i did a bunch of sauce [ __ ]
so that's all i'm saying
okay okay
i could kill andrea
oh [ __ ] that was bad i shouldn't have
done that
oh he's dead that was 100 that was 100
andrea that was 100 andrea literally in
the room that i was in
that was 100 [ __ ] andrea i'm talking
100 why did you run away and not
report the body i i honestly just
panicked that was 100 andrea was in the
room that i was in and i was like [ __ ] i
should have recorded it
i wasn't even over there i don't even
know where the body is oh that's
convenient andrea because you just
murdered someone oh my god alana is
so totally defective right now
no way you guys i was on my way i just
went through decontamination there's no
way that
that body is my is my work i don't
literally saw you coming from there you
wanted 100
[ __ ] dinner wait where is the body
well that's convenient
that's convenient andrew it's like where
the little med bay thing is i had just
done the [ __ ] how did
you do the the telescope thing
nope nope you're not getting away with
this i [ __ ] up by not reporting it and
i recognized that but i panicked it was
100
[ __ ] this up you guys [ __ ] this up
good luck to you
wait i promise i promise that was [ __ ]
up that was [ __ ] up
that is so brutal what the heck it was
[ __ ] up
right i saw it i saw a [ __ ] body
fault i didn't i didn't i hated myself i
hate myself a lot
that's the worst thing that i've ever
done i've never actually played it that
way before if i'm being completely
honest
i've never i've never done that she was
in the room
and i just went for it i just i just did
it okay how's everyone's vitals
great uh zombae did save me there
significantly
i'm really sorry andrea if you happen to
be watching this
um i guess miranda's gone now
that was not a thing that i'm at all
proud of
you know
i've never done that before that was so
awful
oh i love andrea so much
jesus christ but as soon as i saw
steimer i was like [ __ ] it let's
oh oh
okay okay i saw miranda's dead body
outside
the shut door that is the one that is
the room where you walk into and then
you go down and up to electrical
she's right outside the door i can vouch
for this timer
oh wait we already voted her out i'm
stupid never mind
i can vouch for mod mod and i were in
the same area doing tasks
first
has been consistently doing tasks trisha
was then with me
alana you've called two out of two
bodies to be no i didn't call the other
body simon did
i didn't call that this miranda is i can
literally tell you all i saw was i
walked up on a blue dead body she is
right outside a locked door i don't know
who locked it
but right outside a locked door which
would lead to i don't know the the
hallway that then leads to it
i don't know i didn't see anyone all i
saw is miranda's cold
i saw her walking away from a body
all i saw was miranda's corpse that's
all i saw that's uh that's it
i did not kill miranda i won 100
no one's ejected it was a tie i guess i
just don't uh report anyone else
everybody
didn't kill her good luck everyone
didn't do it
because it was zombae who is my
colleague and friend
okay
let's just go this could work you know
this this chaotic energy i've got in
this round could absolutely work
well if we stick together right you want
to just [ __ ]
throw it out because they're not
suspicious of her but they are
suspicious of me
so let's go let's go fam
like it they are they're already
suspicious of me right
like i could just kill whoever and it
wouldn't matter
that's my logic and then we just [ __ ]
get rid of more bodies
andrea i'm so sorry that isn't everybody
else
it is the dirtiest thing i've ever done
in this game i thought you were my
friends
and all of you it was like
let me die by a fiery death it was the
weirdest thing i've
it's the rudest thing i've ever
typically andrea was in that room when i
did it
but so that part wasn't the lie but that
is still the worst thing i've done to
anyone in this game and i was like
i felt so bad i was like i've never
thrown anyone under the bus before i was
like i can't
style walked in the hallway and i was
like i got a display bar
we made clean work at the fastest
imposter win that i've ever had for sure
there was something filling about andrea
being like you guys
[ __ ] up i was like that hit a
like that went a little bit too far she
was in the room she was
in the same room she was just leaving
your pins
orange if someone joins before you
with that it's cause you loaded in and
somebody took your color before you
loaded it oh also holly i killed you
because i felt like you were suspicious
of me so i made sure that i killed you
first
i i i only was suspicious after you
actually did follow me up and i was like
oh no did i make a mistake by
asking her to follow me by doing the
little dance yeah
sorry just so i
did we talk about how quiet zombae was
during that round
yeah because we were silent we put in
good work and when people were
suspicious of me i was like i can just
kind of kill whoever and it's not even
going to matter
because then she could like take the
rest of it because there was nobody left
it was like what good
oh you want muted zombie if you don't
realize maybe she was muted the whole
time it didn't know it's a very quick
question
are the doors supposed to lock normally
or is that a sabotage
it's a sabotage oh okay because where i
went to was pretty much locked
to be clear i i did not kill miranda
that was true i didn't see her die and
did not kill her
that was zombie i didn't know i
didn't kill him my chat my chat was
saying on this map you can unlock the
doors
yeah it's like a little flip
go up next the door you'll click use and
then yeah you click all of the
highlights
i can't believe i got away with that
android
oh my god oh jesus christ okay
okay let's go that was rough this map is
a lot
this map is it is uh throw me in the
lava
i still have my witch hat in my
spaceship yeah she does oh online
she's just changed colors she's pink now
and zombies red
everyone's just swapping around i'm
yelling
okay yeah i'm picking so weird in mine
andrew is pink with no
accessories oh weird oh yeah
that's strange it could be the halloween
update maybe
that was [ __ ] brutal i'm a bad person
[Laughter]
oh holy [ __ ] i'm oh andrea she just she
didn't deserve it and then
i just it's just because i got on it
fast enough
jeez
okay can i get someone to follow me so
that i can do the medbay task in front
of them maybe
but like not somebody who would murder
me like hey
like i just want somebody to follow me
hey hey holly holly holly holly
holly andrea
andrea anyone follow me somebody please
i just what oh wait i turned them off
never mind
that's gonna come badly i'm pretty sure
now everyone's gonna be like a lot of
what are you doing it's fine i can
explain it i can explain what i was
doing
oh my gosh hey
trish
don't kill me trish
are we cool i'm a big fan of what trish
i really like you as a person
and i think you're very cool and i don't
know where my task is oh it's not even
in here
great everything i'm doing is
accidentally suspicious
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa uh
okay okay
so this happens like a confident okay
okay
so i walked down through specimen i was
actually following trish worried she
would murder me uh so
trish absolutely went there before i did
um there was one other person
she was the person who who walked past
us in in uh
the other direction i was going the
other way so
did you see your body then rihanna did
you see bodybuilding no
i was in specimen and then i was trying
to get out and i was very lost
then it has to be trish wait what
so the body is in one of those
decontamination chambers i was following
you trish
which is the one part of this that makes
it seem like maybe it wouldn't be you
because it would be stupid but
it has to be one of the two of you
unless someone happened to go into that
decontamination chamber
and then run out which seems very
unlikely to me or alana is
self-reporting
i mean
[Music]
okay uh
which she was fine though that's the
price
i do think it's her the one thing that
always gets me about this game
is if someone votes for you and then you
vote for them
that's some shady [ __ ] because
someone voting for you doesn't mean
you're a bad guy
i'm gonna go to do the rest of my tasks
down here
holly holly holly holly i don't know
what holly strats are all i know is she
good
so i don't know what she's [ __ ]
playing at okay joey bounced two that
means joey's probably clear
i think my my trish suspicions are
probably on point
a bit worried that i'm gonna get [ __ ]
here
mod okay where is mod so mod was found
in the the lab in the top right i found
some broken glass so i came
down through the specimen room and that
takes a very long time to get through
um and yes i can see anybody
the entire game until i saw monster body
um i know if somebody
went and fixed the alarm thingy i went
and put my hand on one of the alarm
things
and rihanna and i was doing the same i
was waiting for a second person to go
the other one
yeah so ryan you were on the same one i
watched you guys
okay yeah i saw all three of you come
back down after
[Music]
i was in the very very bottom fixing the
wheel and then i went to the left to do
another task so was i the only one on
like the lower left end of the map
i'm on the lower left we're on the right
side i saw you over there trisha
no wait a minute
very confused
[ __ ] oh i just thought that it would be
a hot goof
i didn't i'm playing the imposter
accidentally i mean she may have been
tested
to be fair she may have been sus the
fact that she left now i'm suss of
rihanna
okay now i think maybe rihanna's oh how
do i get him here maybe rihanna's up to
some [ __ ]
unless it was trish and i was right the
whole time right like unless trish
really did pull that [ __ ]
um i didn't actually make that vote in
any confidence though
that particular round i don't know that
she did anything just i made the voting
rounds too short that's what's happened
[ __ ] i'm sorry trish i'm sorry i didn't
i shouldn't have done that i just ah
i just thought
did i is it done what's happening here
am i am i
why am i not doing this right do i have
to press something else
ah i see
yep okay got it that's maybe the first
time i've ever had to do that task
oh hello bruce's ghost isn't here
welcome from i guess they come from
bruce
on twitch on a tweet oh oh oh i'm gonna
i'm gonna get reported for this
i don't feel good about the fact that i
reported it andrea is dead
in the room that is like so i was just
doing
i had done this task for the first time
where you like plug the the oxygen thing
in and then you pull it out and you plug
it in again and i thought that i had
[ __ ] it up because i didn't realize
you had to pull it out and plug a new
one in
um and then i left and andrew is in like
the building that's like one to the
right of
of where all the water [ __ ] is like the
little one
above weapons then right that one yes
it's communications i just fixed the
thing that's over there by all like the
power
line things yeah i just saw i just
passed by rihanna outside of electrical
did someone else die in this round i
think that
i may have [ __ ] up on trish i'm not
sure
there i thought that it wouldn't happen
that way
um i made the voting time too short
i'm just guessing rihanna based on the
fact that i also saw her and specimen
when somebody was dead it feels like
it's too little look at us look at the
split
okay someone's gotta find something
whenever i was going to fix the lights
the only person with me was
re and then
[Music]
i really don't know
i have no [ __ ] idea what's happening
uh is is good man gaming still in here i
would like to get rid of this
there's a person here who needs to be
gotten rid of i believe i've done all my
tasks who do i trust
style style stymo stylist diamond don't
kill me styma
style she could kill me right
wow okay i
holly murdered me so bad vindication
so then it was rihanna who who killed
the body that i thought was trish
it was rihanna when it's rihanna and
holly together you two
are really really happy yeah that was
good
i just asked so alana went hard for me
and so i thought it was alana who it was
not
who was the person that followed up with
you were on the right side of the map
because i was like okay that was great
who did yeah i don't remember who did
i mostly stayed out of the arguments i
think that was what was
good about it
i was like if it wasn't trish it was she
knows if she opens her mouth she is done
for
me so it should be it should be suspect
for everybody
that if we say nothing yeah
whoever whoever was like no trish was on
the right said it was like two seconds
left to vote so i couldn't even be like
oh yeah
the voting time is super short yeah hang
on hang on let me change the voting time
if it was too short
yeah i'll change it i think that also
saved us [ __ ] two
it did say we've also saved rihanna and
i because what do we do
yeah 45 seconds is nothing yeah because
we needed to go
one thing was whenever i went to go fix
the lights ree was the first one there
and i was like okay i i either die or i
fix the lights
and then steiner also came over and says
but i didn't know which one of them it
was like like trish how did you not pass
the body that we had murdered
i didn't see it but i also am horrible
at this map
just a um i think it's because we just
haven't played it very much i i had
zero suspicion of holly to be clear that
whole time i had no suspicion whatsoever
i was like that that's crazy
oh i know it's rihanna and i think maybe
trish i
wasn't sure about miranda because i
thought she jumped in a hole
but i guess i just missed everything so
i was like
and then they won and i was like oh well
never mind
shout out to um zombies new town in that
decontamination
room with me because no i i walked in
and you had already left and there was a
dead body in there
got it
i thought it was a thing that everyone
was supposed to have keys on this map or
is that like with a different game mode
maybe i'm not sure i should have gone
rihanna quarter-ish i
i wasn't positive you know
come do this
she got a gun where did the gun come
from ah i'm dead joey
i'm dead joey i'm dead
oh that was quick okay
i found a body i have
oh well that's who i was going to accuse
wait where was that at i was going to
say
zombae is cool because we're both in the
bottom left by ourselves so
top right in laboratory by the okay okay
yeah because i just came in behind you
because we just fixed that thing there
are so many of us at that little
the little fixing thingy i was all the
way on the far
left side doing the seismic she's quite
yeah okay yeah
wait for a second for someone to do that
um i know steiner was me at the reactor
but she came later as well but
so did the same time as um about joey so
i think we all yeah i saw trisha on
there too i think
yeah there was somebody else there's
like four of us
yeah i was gonna say alana looked
suspicious because
as i was going to react or she stayed
over there but clearly she's dead so
that doesn't make any sense
is there anyone not accounted for or
like
zombae where were you yeah i was just i
was just saying me and zombie were in
the bottom left i was doing this thing
where i was filling up water jugs for
some reason
i'm at the top with joey at one stage
yep more it's quiet as you can tell i'm
gonna skip then
i'm gonna do it i feel like i have to
get more equals quiet equals
that's what i'm
at least you're consistent i'm dead
i'm chatting to them in chat that's the
sentence i just said typing into that
major chord
this has been a really fun one though
like i've had a great time
okay
you're 100 right michael i'm dead and
they're like that's pretty suspicious
alana like i'm just saying you had some
weird behavior
i didn't do any of it
there we go [ __ ] nailed it back to
the specimen room
right okay one two three four five
six seven eight
do we ever just want to acknowledge
that sometimes things are brought up
okay uh don't tell anyone about this
why don't you tell me along that whole
time i'll keep your mouth shut nobody
and then i went over to the left and did
something with the tree inside a
building
okay very defensive for no reason
because nobody saw me and i know it's
gonna come that's a good point
so i'm in the upper right-hand corner um
i was in the lab like
uh doing a thing and then i came back
down over
to run to the specimen thing but miranda
was
her little lump was there but somebody
else ran by me but i don't remember who
they were i was over there and i
remember
seeing it flash like that there was a
body but then you had already called it
but
there was somebody else with you but i
don't remember who i remember do you
remember what color
i remember it's white black and blue
they're with me and
it's quiet i didn't see the body i think
i
don't think it's time my husband the
body's like right below where you were
holly like
if you had gone down instead of over to
the right yeah
i mean yeah i'm just saying like it was
dark so that's why i tried to remember
all the colors but those are the only
ones i remember
mod where were you i'm i'm stuck in the
offices someone shot the doors so i was
just like stuck in a little four by four
for a while
but you can open them and you know that
you like them i can't say
who you know you can open them will you
discuss this on the last round
myself but i think it might be tricia
but i don't know and i don't feel like i
have enough
information yeah it's not enough i don't
i feel like i don't have enough info
either
okay here's the thing we're gonna have
to vote somebody soon
that she knew for [ __ ] sake
hello hi everyone who's alive please
step on yourself thank you
thank you um
all i'm saying is maude's excuse there
after she brutally murdered me
was i was stuck in this little room and
i couldn't get out even though last
round maude had this thing where she
explained that you can flip the switches
to get out of the rooms when they're
locked
and nobody remembered i
i can't tell you how terrible it feels
please get vengeance for me
yeah right we're all dead you know yeah
elvis
was waiting to go to the specimen one
and i was like oh someone's coming out
of the containment chamber
i wonder what's gonna happen and then i
was like joey's right there
there's someone else behind me so
they're going to see whoever kills me
and they didn't see trish and i was like
no oh it is trish
no way
those two are like real good friends too
i bet we're getting some shady [ __ ] from
them
some of these combos are real good like
they just know how to play together
yeah i feel like uh again the mod every
time she's in poster is really quiet
yeah she gets noticeable pretty quiet
yeah i just gotta keep an eye out for it
but then so they
lost round two and they won so what do
we [ __ ] know
it was all [ __ ] but yeah i got uh i
got pretty brutally murdered it's pretty
sad
just doing tasks
all right okay also we've raised six
thousand six hundred and fifty four
dollars everyone
thank you oh yeah i appreciate it oh
there's a dead there's a corpse just
there
just sitting right there yes andrea oh
joey
joey come the wheels are the worst
okay we have to make we have to make a
call here
so what do you find joey is dead in like
the bottom left-hand corner
of the map i don't know what it is so we
lost
zombae and steimer oh my gosh
i just saw steiner so that means the
killer's right next to me and you're
gonna think it's me
where were you i'm i was down in
decontamination
i was i was doing this fossil thing i
was putting like fossils in some dirt
or something where where on the map is
that my dad's bottom right here
everyone family first welcome to my
streams and that's where
so trisha on um andrea steiner and i
were kind of like
all together for a while i feel like
yeah i was just you know
was on the left side andrea was on the
left side north and then went bottom
was she i don't know yeah i went down to
o2 i went down to o2 to do because i
i saw you go right for when the reactor
was going so i went and put my hand on
the left side
and then we cleared it and then i went
down to
o2 to do my task my dad's getting it
going
grand final for the first time i did not
see
so like what would you do about it oh
yeah my dad's fine we just talk a lot
um congrats on getting wait mod you
didn't vote afl final ticket i thought i
did in time and it turns out i didn't
i must have missed it all right we're so
screwed
that rules well the record i i was gonna
vote ryan
oh no hey deafen yourself if you're a
murderer
oh there it is sauce fed squad [ __ ]
did it i knew we were scared boom
it was the stars fed squad they [ __ ]
did it
the voting time is the voting time is
still only 45 seconds
yeah but it's because i made the like
the discussion time longer as well but
i'll make it i'll make it bigger
oh okay i got disconnected oh no so yeah
so now technically we have a minute and
a half right
so discussion time is now 75 seconds and
voting time is 45 seconds
i don't know what the math is on that
nobody asked me i would not like to
discuss math at this time
um good yes
hey trisha
it's pretty good work it was pretty good
um you guys want to do one more bit one
more
rumble yeah yeah let's do it we have
gimme a second
six hundred and something dollars yeah
it's it's uh yeah hold on he's got it
he's gotta get back into the game oh
good i'm halfway through watching
this clip you made of me zombae and i'm
dying
what is it like or is it
something else that's when i when i
killed her last
two years she she tattled it it's always
holly
[Laughter]
i may be out y'all just keeps oh no
you should be you should be okay it
might take a couple tries
to try that many times to get into the
one when i first started playing just
kind of
the one re-entering it yeah
i don't i don't know how to tell you
guys this but like i've been imposter
about three times
and i'm getting less nervous when it
happens
yeah oh it is and here's me just like
i normally i love being a crew mate but
now i'm like i want to be imposter
i can't get i can't get impostor i'll
just keep getting crewmates okay well
it's andrea this time everyone be
sausage
statistically
[Music]
last round you guys got to get a dub
gotta get it done
okay storage
let's go just go in here
try not to die holly why where rihanna
what happened
oh no oh no
i guess she got kicked for some reason
um okay ah
i lose my mouse in this one a lot i just
don't know what happens to it
all right get
more fuel
okay okay okay okay everything's fine
okay outside fuel energies
well i guess we'll go do that instead
and hope the motor doesn't kill me here
because i have seen that happen a few
times anyone anyone anyone
ah okay great
holly what are you up to styma it's dimo
i knew it i know i can use uh spacebar
and [ __ ]
to interact with stuff i just feel like
i'm in a habit in this game of clicking
on things manually
um which i don't have a problem with i
think it frustrates people to watch
someone like not using uh shortcuts but
i have no beef with it
i'm okay with just clicking you know
and using my where'sed
to walk they're not even gonna [ __ ]
find me are they unless someone does
another reactive they're just not even
gonna find
my dead [ __ ] body just dead on the
ground called it alone
just the worst
[Laughter]
okay let's go
i don't know who else it is
oh i guess it's [ __ ] trishy squishy
hershberg should i just saw her event
right
oh trish unless i like completely miss
all that which i have done before but
i'm pretty [ __ ] sure
wait holly as well what's happening have
i missed seen things am i wrong
it's definitely so i don't know what
happened there
no it wasn't joey
so we're totally gonna say joey wasn't
it
um so i found the body and
i was around zombae but zombae was kind
of like
following me directly to going to it so
i believe is safe
but i was kind of in the officey areas
and it was just outside to the right
of like the middle of the map oh i
the last person i saw was zombae but
going my dad's being cute i was leaving
lab as she was going in
it's very
and joey down but rihanna said that she
deceived
yeah i was just disconnected i was not
murdered devastating
um oh i didn't know that alana won as
well
trisha and neither of them so it's me so
steimer and
holly yeah so cyber and i got stuck in
the decontamination room and that would
have been a prime opportunity for
steiner to murder me yeah she didn't
she's
exactly the same with zombae and zombie
could have totally got me
and didn't so that leaves who's been
unaccounted for
i was on the right for a long time until
i went to go turn on the lights and i
was kind of scared because i didn't see
anybody on that side of the map so i
turned on the lights
um and then i went to go do a two tasks
in that area but i did not see
anyone on the left side of the map um
and so i don't know if alana's body is
maybe an o2 because i didn't go into
there
or security so i'm not too sure where
alana would have been but i did see
here yeah that would be tight
i was doing tasks and i saw a lot of
people the one person that i was alone
with for a long time that didn't kill me
was
joey and that happened twice so i was
all excited to come in here and be like
it's not joey
um but yeah then i was so i was in the
you know all the rooms you have to go
through in the upper right and then you
like go in a scene
[Music]
i feel like you're i feel like you're
self-reporting and zombae has inspired
me to vote for people
oh my god when i found the body so
then she's got to sometimes you know
just cast your vote don't waste it
[Laughter]
hey who's around who's that hi i'm dead
[Music]
hey i think zombies are still
did y'all alive kill me i got killed by
her yeah you got [ __ ] murdered dude
you got murdered hard
what yeah just because i think like i
maybe shouldn't have [ __ ] with the
voting time i just felt like we had too
much time previously
so i changed it so we had less time and
then it just ended up being too little
sorry about that yeah hold on so and
andrea voting for me
killed me yeah and it's not andrea so
that's cool
really yeah because i found the body
i mean but that was me like voting out
trish like the same thing like
one round just because i thought that
people would vote for like i thought
people would go no vote
but nobody put anything in so i just
accidentally murdered her
wow you could do that with just one vote
yeah it just has to be a majority it's
holly inside
i guess is it holly and andrew
holly and steima i mean steiner oh i
thought it was zombie
zombie walked right past my body so oh i
could be misremembering but i'm pretty
much positive um
that stymie killed me and then i saw
holly vent
oh really yeah so it's not even andrea
no it's
definitely it's definitely not andrea
yeah just chaotic
oh we hit uh we had six nine six nine
donations everyone nice nice nice nice
size knife thanks
six nine six nines sucks
we can't even win by doing tasks i've
done all my talks
[Music]
who's the gray one i'm in um i'm by the
emergency room
what the dark the dark one the dark like
it's a dark black
gray with the dark color tricia color
yes yes that's it it was trisha oh then
maybe i'm wrong so then maybe holly
didn't bend and it was trisha instead
no holly absolutely killed me oh okay
well
i'm oh andrea's dead yeah
you know the thing on the right side
where you like go all the way around the
map and then i walked into
what is that [ __ ] room uh the one of
the ones that comes like right out of
that and then that's where andrea's
thought was
it's got to be it's like in the office
so i think holly turned on the lights
once
holly did you turn the lights yeah i
mean i turned it on but i saw
i forgot which time it was but like
miranda
i walked over to go turn them on and you
had come on before i got there and i
for sure was the only person who turned
on the last round so that's your game
i also saw zombae turn on the lights
i've been over there to turn them back
on
over there um whenever i was going to
clear that emergency task
the only i saw holly again and i trust
you and so you're running to get it
um i saw trish run up there but i don't
trust trish
so it's tricia
but do you trust i don't remember does
anyone remember what i did it was
diamond
i didn't think that it was on babe but
but then trish and
i don't know like who who was the one
that did a reactor on the right side
because i it was two people
i did i was reactor did we accidentally
make it three
miranda and trish i saw her added but i
was able to click into it and just start
it
you can't but who did it on the left
side then i don't
know or it might be somebody who's like
actually after that zombies
then who was it bobby
i'm going to defend myself i literally
was just vibing everybody and their mom
was happy
we have to pick somebody or else we're
going to lose this
we would have already lost three so then
someone's confused you guys told me you
saw whole event
i thought i saw trishman oh man hi
so i think it's trish not holly but then
chat
is the reason i thought it was holly
sorry no chat's the reason that was
trish
i'm confused guys
and i have things to say i'm confused
about what's happening definitely yeah
everyone definitely definitely okay okay
so
steinberg killed me my chat saying it
might have been holly
they think it was green not trisha
that's what i'm thinking i think it's
holly
and i'm and not trish or the other way
around it's either hall
it's definitely styla definitely holly
she killed me
all by myself okay okay so it's holly
and so yeah whichever one
someone said it was the dark one and
then i was like i think that's true it's
our question
it's not used yeah no it's not zombie
there it is
[Laughter]
but i don't know if it's trish or hawley
it's one of them
even as a ghost that's what i was doing
was being like which one is it is it
trish rosenhauling i don't know
he was very confused but definitely
murdered me in cold blood
i was like having heart palpitations i
was like ah just do it okay
you did a great job that was your first
one right like eva
do you think my first doctor i've been
an impostor before and failed miserably
do you think maybe that the imposters
won this time because
andrea killed me for no reason
definitely what are you talking about i
didn't kill you
definitely assisted killed me campaigned
for her murder
i think it probably would have helped i
didn't think it i didn't really
got rejected my bad already beat our
goal
uh we're actually six nine six nine
right now which i think
is a great time to end the stream
finally inappropriate um but since the
last time
all we did was talk about sex i feel
like well you're the common denominator
aren't you
so whose fault is that you know you were
there both times and then it came
up both times so that's all i'm saying
you got me i like
sex whatever whatever
um thank you guys for joining me thank
you to everyone who donated
uh went now not at six nine six nine
we're now at six nine nine nine which
means someone's gotta donate a dollar
so someone's gotta be caught someone do
it
someone did the donation there it is
seven thousand
thank you and thank you all for joining
me you guys this is super fun this is
like one of the most fun
uh among the streams i've ever done so
thanks for putting this all together
of course what happens when you get too
many ladies who are too
who are too good at deceiving too much
homeboy i'm really sorry andrea
[Laughter]
who's [ __ ] brutal and comfortable i
did her dirty
no no i got the worst i got yeah
tonight and i feel really bad about it
sorry joey it's okay i did the same
thing like a round or two before or
after
so it happens sorry happens i i was
really good at dying
congrats yeah really yeah someone's got
to do it here yeah i'm learning
skill set but i i don't think i'll be
able to apply to my real life so it's
nice to be able to fulfill it here
yes you want his imposter a few times
didn't you
i got it about three three three uh
three times but i i mean
devious yeah we won trisha we won
i have to say i think i won his imposter
twice tonight which is a record for me
so
that maybe means that everyone else is
bad i'm not sure or
or i screwed up the timer or maybe you
you were amazing it could have been any
of the above
i'm not sure i think i kind of had too
good of a night as an imposter because
then
every game that i was crewmate after
that everyone suspected me
it happens um yeah thank you guys for
joining me this is super fun maybe we'll
do it again and thank you everyone who
donated for we we had seven
thousand dollars my goal was only two
thousand five hundred so we [ __ ]
destroyed that
black ops yay so great so much
and i will see you guys